samedi après midi des stationnements
d'épicerie bondé défilent devant les
portes ce qu'on peut décrire comme un
bon achalandage le lendemain les
stationnements sont vides mises à part
quelques québécois en quête de denrées
alimentaires mais qui repartiront
bredouilles
vous avez oublié que cette manche
aujourd'hui exactement de un peu tête en
l'air mais s'est sorti non de tous puis
j'ai vu qu'il y avait personne donc je
suis je suis parti pourrait ne pas farid
si ces plates
je sais pas pourquoi qui en fait
franchement on veut être plus ou moins
retrouvé non syrie dit que monsieur pour
nous cette frustration est palpable du
côté des associations qui représentent
les commerçants c'est une mesure qui a
aidé a absolument rien à la guitare en
la distanciation en magasin ainsi pas
nécessairement de mesures de santé
publique au contraire plusieurs de
toutes parts d'étendre les heures
d'ouverture pour faciliter la
distanciation entre riscle comme on le
fait pour le boxing day du côté du
cabinet du ministre dubé on précise que
les mesures visent à aider les
employeurs aux prises avec un manque de
personnel notamment en raison du nombre
élevé d'absents ce lié à la coved 19 bon
c'est pas une mesure qui répondent aux
besoins des pme en matière de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre ce qu'elles demandent
cette baisse des taxes sur la masse
salariale avoir plus de candidats
notamment en augmentant l'immigration
car n'améliora la communication des
programmes existants certains n'ont
toutefois aucun problème à n'avoir accès
seulement qu'aux pharmacies aux
stations-service dépanneur et service au
volant pendant trois dimanches
consécutifs
je trouve que c'est bien
c'est ce qu'a ouvert hier soir jusqu'à
novare c'est que les gens peuvent se
commander quand même c'est les efforts
qu'il faut faire pour s'en sortir dans
ce contexte le conseil canadien du
commerce de détail lance un appel à tous
les québécois patiente compréhension ici
vif et pour preuve d'empathie auprès des
employés c'était ici quand l'un côté
palette radio canada québec